i've seen flow flows waiting and i had
the game ball and when i when i went up
to them they're just one of those like
i don't know for me it was like thank
you for taking a shot on me
um
because like i said a year ago
i mean
who who would have known i
i could have had a season ending
uh
injury
but you know miami dolphins decided to
take a chance on me so
that was awesome
what is it with these top five
quarterbacks in 2020 not keeping their
first game ball joe burrow sticks it
back in the bag tuatanga vialoa gives it
to brian flores keep the damn ball your
grandchildren want that ball
they got they got bigger things on their
mind they figure they're going to get
balls that are a lot bigger deal than oh
my my first measly win in the nfl you
know these guys are they got high
expectations they put pressure on
themselves and you know with tua i think
it's like a total you know it's a relief
think about his last year of his life i
mean you went from oh i'm going to be
the number one pick in the draft to damn
am i going to come out in the draft wait
is anybody gonna take me in the first
round wait no they are gonna take me in
the first round am i gonna be healthy
enough to play and start the year so i'm
sure he's just so relieved to be out
there and happy that a team believes in
him and it's great to see i know he's
he's a great young man
after uh any of the games in tampa john
gruden never climb up on a ladder and
hand you a game ball no not on a ladder
and he did not climb up on a leg you're
such a jerk he did give me some game
balls though i got i got one or two in
my time down there definitely did you
keep your first one did you keep your
first one i i did i did i got a few
footballs not many in my house i mean
there's not that many to keep really but
yeah i got a few there and uh you know
what was cool too is when you win a game
ball or do something like that then they
would also like give you one that was
decorated with the score and your stats
on it and painted all that that that's
really cool like my little boy phillip
he gets a big you know kick out of
seeing that so that is cool to have
so unlike tua and burro who know that
more coming right you realized i'd
better hold on to whatever i i don't
think i ever hel i i don't think i held
on to like the first win or anything
like i should have i should have been
like damn these are numbered i better
keep this one
but i didn't
all right uh what's more likely for week
10 begins with the game between the
chargers and the dolphins and it is
fascinating because
the dolphins with the fifth pick in the
draft could have taken either guy it's
kind of like a a mini version of peyton
manning ryan leaf just a few picks later
right right and the chargers in the ryan
leaf position yet again they get the guy
who was left over they get justin
herbert herbert has impressed us more in
part because he's played more this year
tua has looked good so what's more
likely justin herbert is the headline
after this game ortua is well
i i think that tua is gonna get the
headlines because i think they're gonna
most likely be the team that wins this
football game you know i don't think
it's gonna be easy but i mean listen we
end up usually talking about the team
that wins i don't know if that'll
necessarily be that he's more impressive
you know like we've talked about i'm
intrigued to see the next step of the
tua offense last you know the first week
he didn't have to do anything last week
it was just screens and boots and oh one
on one go route bam that's all they did
you know they're gonna have to do
something else to bring to the table
against the chargers but you know the
chargers are not a great defense
and uh
i i just think miami's a better football
team but i think like statistically when
it's all said and done
herbert's going to be the guy that wins
that i mean justin herbert is
i don't know what else to say about the
guy him and joe burrow have blown me
away they they really have justin
herbert i think you could sit here and
argue already within him and joe burrow
and go they're top ten quarterbacks in
football maybe already in that
conversation that's how damn good they
are so wow uh yeah they're damn good
justin herbert has an arm that and the
way he throws that
is
it doesn't look as cool mike but damn
like it's every bit as good as rogers
and mahomes and the great arms we have
in the sport right now he can throw more
40-yard lasers like it's nothing and
throw it on the money and i'm just blown
away by it every week
yeah and and justin herbert is good
enough right now yeah to get everyone
fired
in la i mean that that's the problem
right mike they aren't winning games
with this awesome quarterback yet you
have to be apoplectic if you're a member
of ownership there and also as i've said
previously
it makes the job a hell of a lot more
attractive
to any a-list coach out there if you've
got a guy who's been kind of on the
fence and maybe he's being coy and maybe
you think he could get him but now you
know he every every coach is looking for
a quarterback
you've got a situation now with the
chargers this is the kind of job i don't
want to get too far down this rabbit
hole because we're supposed to be doing
what's more likely this is the kind of
job that could catch the interest of
guys currently coaching
other nfl teams head coaches of other
nfl teams and get them wondering is
there a way i can work out a thing where
i can just jump from the team i'm with
to that team all right i can yeah if i
had justin herbert i'm i'm adding to my
legacy in a very meaningful way over the
next five or ten years uh it's gonna be
a very sought after job if it comes to
that you know it really is and i mean
listen if they continue to blow leads
and not be able to manage the clock the
right way and do those type of things it
will be a new regime in there and yeah
all the hot ocs or you know maybe you're
right maybe a head coach or goes uh it's
you know this is coming to an end here
let me go there and start up something
new fresh whatever but when you have
that guy and then some of the you know
receivers in place too around him to go
whoa i could hit the ground running
there we fixed the o line a little bit
and the one thing i know right off the
bat because the defense has talent
already
and you just go i could this offense we
could be special we could be fun to
watch and you know light up scoreboards
and really attract a fan base and do all
those things and they have a chance
right now they do i mean he's special
they hit gold with justin herbert
bill's cardinals another great game this
weekend josh allen versus kyle murray
and by the way going up soon at pft if
it's not there already kyler murphy
halfway to becoming the first ever 4 000
yard passing 1 000 yard rushing player
in nfl history but this topic is about
receivers who's more likely to have
the top production
in the game is it stefan diggs who
currently leads the league with 813
yards or deandre hopkins who
did lead the league before sunday but he
only had 30 yards now he's at 734 who's
more likely to lead that game i think
i'm going to go with stefan diggs here i
am you know the the i think the thing
that they'll just be first off their
offense
josh allen he's always looking for digs
i think the offense is more creative
than arizona that way too to get those
guys the ball
they push the ball down the field more
and arizona you know they they'll give
you those opportunities you know
man-to-man coverage all those type of
things where listen i think hopkins will
have a good day
but i don't know if he'll be on the you
know proverbial island as much with
one-on-one coverage quite to the extent
i think stefan diggs will get and
because of that that's why i'll go with
diggs
yeah it wasn't until the second half
that that kylo murray threw the ball to
deandre hopkins last week which shows
that you know defenses are adjusting and
then the cardinals are adjusting right
yeah if you're going to throw the ball
to the guy 15 times a game at some point
the defense is going to try to take him
away
well exactly right you know and the
other thing too they got going for them
and well you know they need to infuse
other guys in their offense you know
christian kirk as we saw last week he is
a capable guy that makes some big
football plays so you know they did a
great job of featuring deandre hopkins
early we've talked about this before you
know this is where i i dropped the ball
between this and the houston texans
conversation right with like wide
receiver by committee or one guy but
they did the old thing like we're gonna
feed them until people start to adjust
and then we'll be able to adjust off
that and go to other guys um but uh you
know i i again this offense
i don't love it so much of it is on kyle
or murray's and then and his ability
just to make it happen
and i'd like to see them do a little bit
more in the past game too to get
de'andre hopkins more catches down the
field and things like that
huge game between nfc west teams the
seahawks at six and two the rams at five
and three first place on the line what's
more likely jared goff carves up the bad
seattle pass defense or sean mcveigh the
rams head coach tries to play through
the run against seattle chris what's
more likely i'm going to go with the
first one that he carves up the bad pass
bad seattle pass defense now the the the
thing about this question is even within
that they're going to do it through the
run to a degree
but
i think they'll come out with a pass
first mentality you know especially with
seattle seattle like every game it's
it's in your face it's at the line of
scrimmage we're going to take away the
run we're going to do those things you'd
almost be stupid sometimes to come out
and think you're going to run the ball
in seattle they're not going to do that
they're not going to let you do that
early on in the football game but you
know again seattle just undisciplined
all over the place on defense really
have to reassess their approach they
really do and if you're gonna make me
pick up one i'm gonna go he carves it up
with the bad seattle uh pasty
yeah you know i agree with you uh
because that past defense is just so bad
yeah you look at what what josh allen
did to it last week sean mcveigh has to
be saying well i can't wait to get our
offense in a position to take a crack at
that deal it's a different way
you know it's a different way where in
that game i think about it a lot too
because yeah i think they'll have some
ways to take advantage in the past game
but
you know when it comes to the bootleg
play-action pass game that hasn't been
quite as effective against seattle as
the teams that can just drop back and
push it down the field and that's where
i'm like a little tentative about that
match up all together because golf and
mcvay and the rams offense when it comes
to drop back pass game they don't blow
you away that way they're at their best
when they can run it a little and then
that play action and boots come into
into play and uh
that's where you know the the seattle
stopped the 49ers from that aspect and
that's where they might be able to match
up somewhat well here with the rams in
that aspect too
bengals steelers bengals two five and
one coming off their buy steelers
undefeated but ben roethlisberger a
major question mark for that game what's
more likely the steelers defense sacks
joe burrow four or more times or borough
has a chance to win the game on his
final drive this is this is the more
classic what's more like there's a gap
in between there is a gap or i also want
to be like can i pick like he'll
probably get sacked four plus times and
maybe have a chance to still win the
game at the end i mean there's there's a
real possibility of that that it's both
of those
i'm gonna go with here though i'll be
i'll be cool i do think there's a chance
that both of those could happen um
but i think i'm more going to go
with burro get sacked four plus times
i'm not saying that second part doesn't
happen i wouldn't be shocked
um
but i still think there's gonna be times
where he's gonna hold the ball and try
to make something happen and do
something like that
and it'll add to the sack total i don't
think it's just gonna be like oh he's
getting crushed and blindsided all day
but i think he'll make a few plays and
that might get them to four or five plus
sacks
bengals getting two weeks to get ready
for this game influences me and even
though he's been sacked 28 times the
offensive line gave up none in the win
over the titans now maybe that's a
titan's problem not at bengals benefit
the steelers have a league high 32 sacks
and
conversely their last two wins have come
down to a breakup in the end zone on the
final play so i agree with you i think
it could be both yeah i think it could
be both and you know we're doing the
mega pix podcast coming up in a couple
of hours
i'm i may be throwing the dart on the
bengals
maybe
it might be time to be time for the
steelers to take an l it might be
especially with this ben issue with the
two injured knees and the covet 19
reserve list designation all right bucks
at panthers last one what's more likely
mike evans chris god when antonio brown
is the most productive receiver trio or
robbie anderson dj more and curtis
samuel take that title wow
man there is some and no christian
mccaffrey i know christian mccaffrey for
the panthers there is some talent there
you know
uh um i don't know here this one's a
really close one i i think i'm i'm gonna
go with brady and evan i mean godwin and
brown i'm gonna go with them i don't
feel comfortable about that
but i gotta think tampa is gonna be a
different football team this week a
little bit more pissed off they
definitely have a better secondary than
carolina carolina plays a little
conservative on the back end which
scares me to go oh maybe they won't let
up a lot of big pass plays but i'm still
gonna go uh with the bucks guys here
bruce aryan said this week he wants less
from antonio brown that 39 snaps was too
much he had intended right and they want
they want to get away from the three and
four receiver sets because that takes
the tight ends off the field it makes it
harder for the running game right i've
been saying that all week i did you know
right then i come in monday morning
going where the all the stuff that brady
and tampa did good they just were like
oh we got antonio brown screw everything
we did we're just gonna go shotgun no
don't i thought they told us they got
him for insurance not that they needed
him right isn't that what they were
telling us
i mean they acted like they needed them
the other day no they don't get them too
tight enough run the ball make brady
feel comfortable with extra protection
to throw the ball down the field and
when you want to take godwin out of the
game or one of them then you put antonio
brown in but that's their best best
offense to me
yep tug of war between bruce aries and
tom brady over antonio brown and we'll
see how it plays out this weekend
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports